a global crisis
needs global leadership for most of the
past 75 years
that leader has been america
no longer leaders held an online summit
today pledging billions to develop a
coronavirus vaccine
notably absent from the meeting were any
officials from the trump administration
i'm instructing my administration to
halt funding of the
world health organization america's
retreat has left a vacuum at the top
every time that america steps back
that's an opportunity for china to step
forward and present
itself as the champion of the world
order
has china spotted an opportunity to
steal a march on america
and use the soft power of global
diplomacy to hasten its rise
as the world's top power
there's one thing we must learn it's one
world
it's a world in which we must all get
along
and it's my opinion that this great
republican lead the way
as the second world war drew to an end
plans were put in place
to keep the peace the united nations and
other newly created institutions
performed the backbone of a rules-based
world order
and america was the chief architect and
leader
united nations have been working for
eight weeks to produce a charter on
which the future of world peace will
depend
since its creation in 1945 the
membership of the un
has grown from 51 countries to 193
its activities and those of its
specialized agencies
span almost every aspect of life
we have before us the opportunity to
forge
for ourselves and for future generations
a new world order
but after successive presidents
committed to leading and shaping the
world
president trump has pulled america in a
very different direction
the future does not belong to globalists
the future belongs to patriots the
future belongs to sovereign and
independent nations
under donald trump's presidency america
has been
a quitter of international arrangements
and institutions
as well as withdrawing funding for the
world health organization
a un agency president trump has pulled
america out of
the paris agreement on climate change
the nuclear deal with iran
and he abandoned the trans-pacific
partnership the giant trade agreement
that was close to completion
i think this is all part of um the
america first
idea there's a long history of america
fearing
being held down by by smaller powers but
it's taken a particularly strong form
under donald trump you know what i am
i'm a nationalist okay
america is so central to an order that
has
really stood the world in good stead for
75 years
if america withdraws everybody else is
extremely
worried about what will maintain this
order in its absence and whether the
rules of the game are actually going to
be adhered to in future the country that
has stepped into the void left by
america
is china china is becoming more and more
powerful
on the economic front technologically
and increasingly geopolitically as well
over the past two decades china's
contribution to the un's regular budget
has increased from 1 to 12
while america's has remained the same
china has been methodically increasing
its influence in existing institutions
not least the un chinese nationals now
had four of the un's 15
specialized agencies americans lead
just one china is has become in
recent years um increasingly assertive
in the way that it pushes
its interests it's not afraid anymore to
use quite strong-armed tactics it's not
afraid to use
its veto in the security council
[Music]
security council vetoes can tell us a
lot about the balance of power in the
u.n
during the cold war america used its
veto regularly
but in the past decade it's used it just
three times
china on the other hand has increased
its use
but the country exercising its veto
power most in recent years
is russia it does seem to be an alliance
of convenience between china
and russia both share an interest in
not having western countries become too
busy body in their human rights for
example
to be able to act uninhibitedly in their
rather authoritarian
ways whether over the long term that's
sustainable is debatable because russia
is after all a declining power
compared with china which is a rising
power and russia may come to
find its embrace of china distinctly
uncomfortable
in march 2018 france proposed that the
un security council
heard a briefing on human rights abuses
in syria
but russia and china opposed the session
the provisional agenda has not been
adopted it having failed to obtain a
required number of votes
the meeting is adjourned
china managed to prevent that by
lobbying very hard with
ivory coast former french colony which
switched sides at the last moment and
that's those sort of little incidents
are wake up calls for the west that
china's
influence is really starting to be felt
what's more
chinese officials have been inserting
favored chinese wording
into un documents phrases like win-win
cooperation
phrases that refer to the belt and road
phrases that take
a rather chinese view if you like of
of human rights cumulatively it can have
the effect of creating a chinese
friendly environment
for these multinational institutions
china has also been building channels of
influence
outside the institutions that america
designed
it has set up the asian infrastructure
investment bank
which encroaches on the world bank's
territory
and created the shanghai cooperation
organization
an eight-member group that includes
russia india
and pakistan it's not obvious that china
actually wants to use serp america's
role in the sense of taking on wider
responsibilities for the global order
but it certainly wants to make the world
safer for chinese
expansion this has worried those in the
west
not least because of china's attitude
towards human rights
if china does continue its rise in the
west retreat
then i think human rights would be in
trouble and that one of the criticisms
of the secretary general
is that he hasn't put human rights front
and center
and defended them as as
prominently as he might have done you
can watch antonio gutierrez
the un secretary general responding to
this and other questions the economist
put to him
by clicking on the link above
there has been some pushback from
america in january the state department
appointed a senior diplomat
mark lambert to counter the so-called
malign influence
of china and others at the u.n
but there is a sense that america is
perhaps no longer as dependable
as it once was you hear talk of
countries getting together
to try and keep this rules-based liberal
order
going um it's not easy to do this
without the real impetus that comes from
a power with the size and the weight
that america can put behind it
but smaller efforts at least can make
some difference
kovid 19 has shown that the biggest
problems cry out for international
efforts
climate change is a challenge that no
country can tackle alone
the same is true for organized crime and
cybercrime
a new president in the white house might
give america a renewed interest
in looking outward again but the un and
other global bodies
also need to reform their 75 year old
structures
are not designed for a 21st century
world
perhaps it will take something of a
crisis to make it happen
and to give countries the push they need
to modernize the institutions
the coronavirus pandemic has hijacked
the global agenda
it also presents an opportunity the
upheaval could spur countries into
strengthening the liberal world order
but if america fails to reassert its
global commitments
china's diplomatic power will continue
to grow
i've written a special report about the
united nations 75 years after its
founding
and how it's struggling to adjust to
changes in world power
especially the relationship between
america and china you can read it by
clicking the link
opposite thank you for watching
[Music]